The Going Digital Project is an opportunity to achieve some of the social...
...and policy goals we've been pursuing for a long time...
...whether it be in climate change...
...or dealing with aging populations or income inequality.
The speed of what's happening really challenges the existing institutions...
...that we have for policymaking.
It's clear that jobs and skills will be directly affected...
...and it's gonna be sectors that maybe haven't seen automation...
...come to them before,...
...sectors like law, education, finance.
We're  already seeing some great examples across the OECD.
Estonia is beginning to use blockchain already.
We're seeing Mexico beginning to use electronic verification of invoices...
...to make sure tax evasion doesn't occur.
In Paris, people using the technology to whether rent a bike...
...or to get out an electric vehicle for use across the city.
Governments need to do a few things.
They need to be proactive.
They can't be reactive.
They need to be able to begin to look at the transition...
...and begin to do some of that forward planning.
They have to look at the human capital, the people themselves,...
...and that means equipping them with the skills where they can,...
...and these skills will be constantly changing.
We have to get used to that.